the show basically opens with her life
um uh which is
living with her lovely handsome husband
cobb played by dan
who's kind enough to be here today and
um
and and basically she seems to have this
pretty
good life ostensibly um she has
a very close friend who is also her
manager uh naomi jones played by
uh the beautiful layla um so i have to
say beautiful very
this is what people are like in the show
no um it's and
everything seems to be fine in fact she
gets this this bit of good news
at the beginning of episode one which is
she's going to play a
disney princess in a new um movie
and she can't quite believe it she
thought her career was on the skis
anyway and then throughout the course of
episode one it becomes clear that
something else has happened which is
a mass leak of stolen images
in which she's included which is going
to affect every area of her life and the
episodes basically
roll through the different areas of her
life that it affects
in hopefully unexpected and interesting
ways
that you might not necessarily assume um
emotionally and professionally
particularly
and each of the episodes and georgie the
director can speak quite a lot to this i
think because this was one of the great
things that um you know she brought to
the show which was the
you know the way of visualizing how each
of the episodes should feel different
because they're each stages that susie
goes through in dealing with this
kind of violation and trauma and
exposure hi everybody thank you so much
for joining us here at this wonderful
bafta q and a
uh the sky original that you can watch
um
on sky atlantic in sky now on the 27th
of august from 9 p.m
two episodes and then it will all be
available as well to watch
i've been lucky enough to watch two
episodes which is brilliant to be able
to chat to this wonderful panel about so
without further ado uh please welcome
lucy prebble the series writer
co-creator and executive producer
of this uh billy piper plays suzy
pickles co-creator and executive
producer
uh leila farzad who plays naomi suzie's
manager and best friend
so much to talk about uh and daniel ings
who plays
cop susie's husband georgie banks davis
the director
andrew jewsbury producer and myself um
hi everybody thank you so much for being
here
hi there hi there and we will give you
guys
as well who are joining us the chance to
answer ask some questions
i'm going to selfishly dive in first and
ask all the questions i want to ask and
you can put yours
in the q a section i'll get through as
many of those as i possibly
can as well uh lucy
um where did this where and how did this
idea start i believe it was quite a
while ago the conversations or the seeds
of these
this character and this story started
yeah it was probably about five years
ago now
at least i think and um billy and i
were having a drink somewhere which
isn't unusual and had a conversation
um about something or other in life
i think something was going on in one of
our lives and i remember it was probably
the first time that billy said to me
you know we should do it we should try
and make a tv show again because we have
worked
together originally in a show called
secret eye of a cool girl many many
years ago
and we were both much much younger and
um
we were having this conversation as as
friends
and we started to sort of think in a
very casual way what would it be
if we were going to do that it took
quite a long time from that point to
come up with what eventually became i
hate susie but i wrote quite a
few versions of the first episode that
were really different from what it ended
up being
that was actually more of a sort of
friendship sitcom actually originally in
the very very early days between two
women
and then um but i kept having this
pervasive feeling of sort of
so what like so so what what's the thing
what's the thing
because i like something quite big and
meaty and dramatic to sort of get my
teeth into and
eventually i was sort of thinking and
chatting about never having actually
found out what happened in the case of a
lot of the women
who had had their um iclouds hacked if
you remember
back a number of years ago it was huge
and it was really
devastating and massive and and
upsetting and
and yet nothing nothing sort of
consequentially seemed to be in the news
after that which i always found really
sort of surprising
and i don't just mean criminally
necessarily i mean more
sort of emotionally um and
professionally
actually in terms of them talking about
it it felt like it all had to go
underground in a sort of terrible state
of shame
and so i started to think what would
that be like if your whole life was kind
of exploded
through these images and that's kind of
where the idea originally
came from billy why did why did you want
to um
why did you was actually first of all
how did you find
creating susie because you know we start
this we start the series and
and the clever and brilliant thing that
you've done is each episode is almost
an emotion or a reaction to her
experience but
it kind of very much feels that she
doesn't really know who she is
herself in a way and was that an
exciting opportunity to create a
character like that that almost she's on
a journey of discovery throughout this
entire series
yeah um absolutely and i think
the hack was a great way to unmask
this woman um and this character and
certainly
um chimed with a lot of conversations
that lucy and i had been having about
your late 20s early 30s being this sort
of rude awakening
and how quite often and certainly
conversations i've had
amongst my friends you sort of uh
a common theme seems to be i don't know
who i really am i don't
know i do you know i feel like i
should be more established at this point
or um
i am sort of established in the eyes of
the world and actually i don't want any
of that
and i am constantly
trying to appeal to people but who am i
and this was a great
way the hat was a great advice in terms
of exposing
um a woman and what it is we sort of go
through
from birth until you know late 20s early
30s which feels also like something we
don't talk a great deal about
so we took a great deal about our
twenties
um but then
oh police forces that gives a lot
you know that gives us a lot to sort of
play with
and yeah this awful incriminating
thing happens um but it's sort of
it it helps her find herself
ultimately so where do we explain to
people who maybe haven't seen it yet
where we find
susie pickles at the start of this this
series
um well please
oh um so the show the show basically
opens with her life
um uh which is living with her
lovely handsome husband cobb played by
dan
who's kind enough to be here today and
um
and basically she seems to have this
pretty good
life ostensibly um she has a very close
friend who is also her manager
uh naomi jones played by uh the
beautiful layla
i have to say beautiful very beautiful
but now i'm like now
that's all that matters to us exactly
exactly aesthetically
this is what people are like in the show
no um it's and
everything seems to be fine in fact she
gets this this this bit of good news at
the beginning of episode one which is
she's going to
play a disney princess in a new um
movie and she can't quite believe it she
thought her career was on the skids
anyway and then throughout the course of
episode one it becomes clear that
something else has happened which is
a mass leak of stolen images
in which she's included which is going
to affect every area of her life and the
episodes basically roll through
the different areas of her life that it
affects in hopefully
unexpected and interesting ways that you
might not necessarily assume
um emotionally and professionally
particularly and each of the episodes
and georgie the director can speak quite
a lot to this i think because this was
one of the great
things that um you know she brought to
the show which was the
you know the way of visualizing how each
of the episodes should feel different
because they're each stages that susie
goes through in dealing with this
kind of violation and trauma and
exposure
yeah i think in episode one as well
she's sort of hysterically holding
everything
together and that we very
quickly learned um
you know that she's um i would say kind
of
quite on the edge um
and then you know these things happens
and it totally blows
everything apart and that's you know
that's satisfying
hopefully to watch but certainly to play
[Music]
you